let's talk about the miami dolphins now
that's a potential destination for
desean watson brian flores though
he's got to love the one he's with and
the one he's with is tuatonga by lower
the fifth overall pick in the 2020 draft
here's coach flores from yesterday
talking about what he hopes to see from
tonga viloa
between year one and year two of his nfl
career
i'm excited about you know tua in this
upcoming season i think uh
you know we we you think about his
situation last year coming off the hip
and we started nine games uh i thought
he made a lot of improvement rather
really throughout the course of the
season
uh had some ups had some rounds um
like all the rookies um and like any
rookie uh
i'm really excited about this uh this
this
you know that year one to year two jump
year one to year two may come somewhere
else though you can't rule out anything
with the dolphins especially if they
could get deshaun watson
all due respect to tuatanga viloa we've
seen enough
from him to know he's not going to be
a great shortlist franchise quarterback
he could prove us wrong
before giving him the motivation to
prove us wrong so be it great i hope he
is i like him i think he's a great kid
but you either have it or you don't
justin herbert has it joe burrow has it
two a dozen
if they can get to sean watson they
gotta run with it and that's one of the
few places where it makes sense they've
got the draft capital to pull it off if
they want to do it
and who knows does tua go to houston
does he go somewhere else but
if they can't pull it off then he
presumably will get another year
peter with or without a relief pitcher
whether it's ryan fitzpatrick or someone
else
and uh we'll see what what do you think
this this plays for tua going forward
whether it's with miami or somewhere
else have you seen enough from him to
think
he can get to that level of franchise
quarterback
well there's two two teams that i think
are best suited uh obviously the two
teams that are best suited to trade
for tua our trade for watson are the new
york jets sitting there at number two
and the miami dolphins sitting there at
number three
but i believe that the dolphins have a
better chance to trade for
uh you know a franchise quarterback like
uh like watson because i just think that
from
everything i'm hearing that joe douglas
is really enamored
of building this team through the draft
and not basically uh ripping away
all of the draft choices and all of
these
yeah you know they've got a much better
chance in miami i think
um to put together a trade that would be
the kind of bold trade that would take
it
but mike the other team i think that has
a very good chance to trade for him
if indeed he is traded uh is the
carolina panthers at number eight
the draft pick isn't quite as good
obviously as where
miami is but the reason why i think
carolina will be in the picture at some
point before this is over
is that that owner wants a franchise
quarterback
he's not used to people telling him no
and so i think he's going to trade more
than any other general manager might
want to trade
maybe even including his own scott
federer but
i do think that the carolina panthers
are going to be involved
if there ever is an auction for deshaun
watson
you're absolutely right david tepper
very determined to get a franchise
quarterback
whether it's deshaun watson whether it's
possibly russell wilson although
wilson hasn't included the panthers on
his list of
preferred destinations or trade up in
the draft to get one of the top guys
we don't know where desean wants to go
we've heard bits and pieces there's been
reports he's intrigued by the broncos
and there's a thought that the dolphins
are
choice number one but unlike russell
wilson whose agent 15 days ago
announced the four teams for which
russell would play we haven't gotten
that yet from david mullighetta or from
deshaun watson so we just don't know and
some have said oh he wouldn't want to go
back to carolina well he was a star
clemson i don't i
i i wouldn't i wouldn't rule out anyone
until
we hear something directly or indirectly
from desean watson one thing we do know
about the houston texans is that they've
signed mark ingram to a one-year deal
worth
up to three million dollars anytime you
hear up to
that means there's incentives there's
other things he's got to do
and one thing he's got to do is be on
the roster week one this is a guy who's
been around for 10 years david johnson
is the starter there
this just may be a stabilizing presence
in the offseason in training camp
because david culley knows him
and it could be at the end of the day
doesn't make the week one roster peter i
mean this is a guy who once he was cut
there hasn't been a land rush for his
services and he's done some good things
in the past
but with running backs there's a shelf
life and there's a chance he's reached
that expiration date we'll find out
but uh he's been he's been available to
every team and he goes to a place where
he's acquainted with the head coach
and he has a chance to contribute in
that running game but clearly he's not
the top guy
yeah and mike the one other factor
in all of this is that you know i i
reported a couple of weeks ago that
uh that nick casario was not even
countering
was not even considering any offers
which
is the right thing to do it is
absolutely the right thing to do
at this point in time now
let's just say we get to august 23
august 24
and then let's say that nick casario on
monday of draft week calls five teams
and he says
you got until eight o'clock tonight to
come up with your best offer
give me your best offer by eight o'clock
tonight we'll have a decision for you
by wednesday morning however you would
do that
but i think there is some attract there
would be some attraction to me
basically to do a blind auction that
would take advantage of david tepper's
eagerness and that would take advantage
of a team
that desperately wants them to maybe
throw in that you know you've already
let's say because i think carolina's
gonna have to offer three ones
so let's say you not only offer three
ones and and you've offered
a couple of other things now you go
beyond that you say
we'll give you our next two threes you
know or something like that
but if the houston texans end up
trading uh desean watson
you look at that roster right now that
roster basically is an expansion team
roster
and you you in essence
have to get enough material
and and enough young players out of this
thing
to rebuild your roster and and mike i'll
say one other thing
i'd rather have the draft picks in 2022
than 21
because as i wrote last monday this is a
bad year
to pick players and to assume that guys
who might have only played
one year and then opted out i mean
how do you know who you're drafting and
that's why
if i am a gm if i'm nick casario
i want the bulk of these picks in 22 and
23.
yeah that's a great point the draft is a
crap shoot it's going to be even more of
one
this year than ever before even more of
one than last year
because of the limited games the guys
opting out no scouting combine
no opportunity to bring guys in it's
going to be difficult when it comes to
making those pics
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports